let's get reaction tonight from the
senior Republican on the House Judiciary
Committee Georgia congressman Doug
Collins joins us right now from Tucson
Arizona congressman thanks for being
here you heard those two reports your
reaction to this
IG report on James Comey well for those
of us have been following this for two
years the IG report continues what the
lastt IG report says and that the James
Comey was someone who cannot be trusted
James Comey had a personal vendetta he
believed it his role in the FBI was one
that he was the ultimate arbiter our
being judge and jury on anything that he
did or did not like the problem we're
finding here is is and he can say
anything he wants to he can say that he
didn't lie but we know he did he pied to
the FBI when he told him he was not
truthful about what he did with some of
those memos we can tell that he leaked
because he had used a third party mule
his attorney or others if you want to to
actually get the memo out there and he's
also very disingenuous because you can
see right through him and it's just a
joke for him to go on Twitter and ask
for somebody to apologize to him I got a
better idea when he why don't he take
his white robe that he's been wearing
around and noticed the strains on him
when he gets those things out from lying
then maybe somebody else can apologize
to him all right Congress there are a
lot of people watching these
investigations and they're saying well
what now what happens now where does
this go
do you have any answers well I think
we're still there I think this is one
part of the Inspector General's report
this is one part of things that are
still left to come I think mr. Comey
again I've talked about this with McCabe
Comey struck the all corrupt cabal that
was there they've still got a lot of
things to worry about how they handled
the you know what it's gonna be I
believe coming in the FISA investigation
the complete FISA investigation not just
this piece that came out I think mr.
Durham is still looking into these
issues as well I think at this point in
time what the American people ought to
know is is that after two years of are
more of going after then candidate Trump
now president Trump and having a DOJ
that was you know harassing at every
point now they have we have an attorney
general bill Barr who said we're gonna
get to the bottom of this we have an
expected general who's continuing his
work and we have another US attorney
who's looking into the wrongdoing that
was believed to be done by that point so
I think we still have a lot left to go
if I was some of this corrupt cabal I
think I'd still be worried all right
after his book came out April 20 18 I
had James Comey on this
asked a number of questions about
various topics including the specific
handling of these memos I want you to
listen to this this clip large clip and
then get your reaction I sent mr.
Richmond a copy of a two-page
unclassified memo and asked him to get
the substance of it out to the media did
you leak other things through mr.
Richmond
yeah like others I'm smiling Brenda I
don't consider what I did with mr.
Richmond a leak I told him about an
unclassified conversation with the
president FBI protocol says your own
employment agreement with the FBI
prohibits quote the unauthorized
disclosure of any information or
material from or related to FBI files or
any information acquired by virtue of my
official employment without prior
written permission from the FBI did you
have written written permission no and I
didn't consider it part of an FBI file
all the things I talked about with an
FBI director he was a what product no it
was not it was my personal resident sure
I created two copies of it want to keep
in my personal safe at home and I left
another with the FBI so the bureau could
always have access to it but I always
thought of it as mine like a diary who
else did you give leaked hell or
whatever you want to call it yeah I gave
the memos to my legal team after I gave
him to Dan Richmond after I asked him to
get it out to the media you said in the
memos I said I don't do sneaky things I
don't leak I don't do weasel moves but I
mean we can argue what a leak is but
that's a leak isn't it it's not okay
here's what you told chuck grassley
about leaking director Comey have you
ever been an anonymous source in those
reports about matters relating to the
Trump investigation or the Clinton
investigation never has any classified
information relating to President Trump
or his associations associates been deep
classified or and shared with the media
not to my knowledge
so at what point were you made aware
that some of the information was
classified by the FBI which ever
mentioned in the memos oh yeah I don't
know sometime after I was fired
so when you hear all of that congressman
your thoughts well it's just it's just
sad I mean here I mean he's talked about
weasel moods so this is the ultimate
weasel I mean he knows what he does I
mean to try and blame it all on other
people that I didn't leak he used a mule
mr. Richmond and that's what I call it
because that's what he's trying to
portray himself as if somebody
disconnected from this he's not James
Comey knows exactly what he was doing he
knew exactly what he did to claim those
were personal documents let's also
remember he said that he had no personal
relationship with the president and that
he wouldn't have been invited to the
White House had he not been FBI director
well that tells me he's admitting right
there that he was in an official
capacity because he said he didn't have
a personal relationship with the
president and those notes were taken for
one intents purposes only and that was
he did not like this president you can
see from the past experience of them
investigating it up through there and I
think they were just use for that so you
know for him to claim innocence and now
to go back and try and spin this as if
something was done to him that's a joke
and the American people see right
through congressman Democrats like
Senator Chris Murphy from Connecticut
say thank goodness that Comey kept these
memos that the nation is better off for
it because then it produced a special
counsel that detailed the Russian
interference in 2016 and a whole lot of
other things in that report well I think
the senator is badly mistaken I think
what he did was here's he started a
special counsel because he wanted to get
at the president he wanted always to
disavow this presidency and make sure
that this president was not able to
function because he was always having to
be looking over his shoulder this is
what he did the reason he kept these
memos were not for a noble purpose we
need to get this out of her head Jim
Comey was not acting as Captain America
he was acting as a cutter agent at the
FBI because he wanted his own agenda put
for keeping these memos started us down
a Special Counsel report that ended and
mr. Muller finding there was no rush
inclusion there was no time that the
president did anything or as if his team
did anything with Russia that would have
mounted to collusion in that essence
that's been put to bed and then the mr.
Muller himself when we T was testifying
before our committee he went through
these with the Democrats what they would
say is this this and this and then he
would get to the end and say I don't
agree with your legal conclusion so from
mr. Murphy to say to waste 30 million
dollars on a witch hunt they're
basically started because mr. Comey
didn't like the president I think you
need to turn the question around and say
what part of that is
actually really good last thing you said
you think that the rest of the IG report
is coming soon do you have any inside
knowledge about when that's going to
drop no I think it's still coming in
from what we've been telling it'll come
it's we've been thinking in the
September timeframe I think those are
just the the indications that we have
and I think for the American people
again what they can be safe is now that
there was a corrupt cabal at the
beginning of 2017 in the end of 2016 and
they will in the Department of Justice
in the FBI they're gone that has now
been put to rest and I think we can now
begin to move forward with the Justice
Department that can be trusted unlike
when you had Jim Comey as FBI director
who tarnished the trust of a great
organization tarnishment Doug Collins
joining us from Arizona congressman
thanks thank you very